the spread of the delta variant across
the u.s is putting new attention
and pressure on people who have not been
vaccinated
in five states less than 50 percent of
the eligible population has received at
least one shot
wondering which one has the least
vaccinations well it is mississippi
omar villafranca is in cleveland
mississippi in the region known as
the delta omar what's going on there and
what are people doing to try to fight
the spread
good morning covett covet
hospitalizations have more than doubled
here in mississippi since the start of
july so
to boost those vaccination rates the
state is offering free rides on
community bands like this one here in
the delta
to take people to get those shots and at
one of the centers
we met a woman who was doing her very
best to try to coach her community
through covet
sixteen-year-old john eubanks is
supposed to get his first dose of the
pfizer vaccine
but he's a little nervous football and
also
come on now so coach t is here to give
him a pep talk it's gonna be like
a little mosquito bite that's all
after eubanks rolls up his sleeve and
gets the
what shot is it
vaccinations denise taylor is the clinic
operations manager at the delta health
center in mound bayou mississippi
before that she coached women's
basketball in the wnba
and at jackson state university now
she's doing a different kind of
recruiting
going out into the community to convince
her neighbors to get vaccinated
and asking them to spread the word all
right well i'm going to be counting on
you
to recruit some more people what is it
like for you
when somebody you've talked to for 30 to
45 minutes
and then you see them coming at a
vaccine oh my goodness
it's like it's like winning the game
people are tired of hearing from elected
officials they're tired of hearing from
doctors about it yes
but they'll hear it from a coach yes
taylor is worried about the delta
variant which is responsible for the
majority of mississippi's new cases
but even with the variant on the rise
enthusiasm for the shot
is still low on this trip the community
bus
only brought in two patients is that a
win
absolutely i mean if you can get
one person to get the vaccination it's a
win
what's the win is to bring the numbers
up here in mississippi
you told no more than you told yes so
when i'm told no
i say i respect that you know but you're
still gonna try but i'm still gonna try
i'm a coach so you know i don't want to
be last at
anything
taylor says convincing people to get the
shot is about trust
and perspective for 16 year old john
eubanks it's about him getting to go
back to school
and play high school football again for
other people it's about the health
of a loved one but so far this program
in this particular community
has already taken more than 700 people
to get their shots
anthony coach denise taylor doing some
great work down there in the delta omar
thank you very much